hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dinner party now dinner
party is a game where you host a dinner
with a party of people you have a dinner
party it's a party dinner it's a dinner
party you take the dinner and the
partying you bash them together and you
make a dinner party have I made myself
clear it's a dinner party so there were
no instructions in this nightmare of a
game I have no idea okay ah I'm just
gonna let this one die because I know I
feel like I walked into the wrong dinner
party here and I don't think I have any
idea what I'm doing here
my whole introduction about this game
was probably for naught and I have no
idea what's happening I am so scared I
believe I'm going to die let this one
just rot gasp I say this dinner is a
ruse congratulations your score was 78 I
don't know what that means
dinner party is a short game where you
pretend house to dinner party can you
convince the guests they are real with
who are there with real humans you're
convincing acting and wit will win you
the day as you compete for who can keep
the guests belief the longest control
puppets using the first letter of the na
so I think the point of this game is to
convince you guys that this is real
because there's no one else here besides
me and my dinner guests so I'm just
going to lay down the masterpiece of
this family meeting and we're going to
have a great time here at this dinner
party are we all right I'd like to start
this meeting of excuse me does a little
early Diana I'd like to start this
meeting if you jokesters can just shut
up I get started with the meeting about
that I'd like to start this meeting of
the jacksepticeye impersonators Club
this is our 13th meeting I think the
others have gone very well this past few
weeks I'd like to thank Reginald in the
back especially don't be shy Reginald
there there's a Reginald yeah top of the
morning to you laddies oh that was good
yeah no it was great
no that's good you can stop now that'd
be great yeah so in our thirteenth week
you might be asking yourselves what does
it take to become a good jacksepticeye
in personally well say with me
pardon do you not know
all right I called you guys here for
this meeting of the ugly people to come
to terms with the fact that we're all
really [ __ ] ugly
I know I know Reginald you especially
Yvonne you don't need to try to be best
at this one being ugly is not a winning
thing so how do we deal with being ugly
look don't speak out of turn Jeremiah
I'm gonna slap you even uglier than you
already are
uh hi no that's very funny can't be done
- look Reginald and I have been talking
about this and we think that there's a
way to solve our problems if we could
just so Chad blueberry if we just stop
stuffing our gourds for one second no
I'm not saying being fat makes us ugly
I'm saying our fucked-up faces makes us
eat as much as you want that's not the
point here look the point is that we're
ugly and we got to do something about it
we've got to change other worlds got to
change around us look hey come on don't
be so rabble-rousing about that oh come
on
okay all right look guys I know you guys
are look at me a disbelief but yes I
called this meeting of those who have no
ass I am aware I know it's a sensitive
subject Diana
shut the [ __ ] up for a second let me
talk look I know we all have no asses
and it's fine we live with it we love it
we're fine with it we are our parents
accepted us even though they threw us in
the woodford not having asses in the
first place but that's not the point the
point is that we're here now we all made
it this far in life because we have no
ass not despite it we are stronger for
not having to meet cheeks between our
buttocks we are better than our
forefathers who threw us out say that we
were now who's with me who is with me
[Music]
all right I'd like to start this meeting
of the people who are very bad at video
games no not video games I said video
games and I meant it what okay whatever
it's video games Diana just shut the
[ __ ] up for one goddamn second look
obviously I'm bad at video games yes my
name is markiplier I'm bad at video
games I get it all of you are just the
same as me look maybe there's something
that we can do without being good at
video games maybe we could still
play video games and be bad at it but if
we scream real loud and make a lot of
funny facial expressions because all of
you guys just like me are incredibly
ugly yes especially you Diana shut the
[ __ ] up all right look we're all
incredibly ugly
we're not likeable in the least I mean
in fact we have very few positive
qualities amongst all of us I mean split
evenly down the middle I mean I'd say
Newberry is the worst off over there but
I'd say none of us have any
extraordinary talents listen to me
listen to me this is new thing called
YouTube if we just make videos put our
faces on it and just scream at video
games and look look we don't have to be
good we're not gonna embarrass ourselves
or actually we are gonna embarrass
ourselves because it's gonna be
completely ridiculous what we're doing
look if we put it on the internet maybe
we can make something out of it maybe we
can have a career out of it okay you
[ __ ] just laughing at me whoa
who's gonna be laughing when I'm I'm I'm
the king of this new YouTube thing and
then you guys can all just shut up and
eat a dick sorry I say something to
offend you oh 95 all right thank you for
Diana shut the [ __ ] up all right I'd
like to thank you all for meeting with
me
at the eve of this auspicious occasion
we're here to commemorate the absolute
low point of markiplier spin I know you
all thought it couldn't get any lower
I'm Diana again shut the [ __ ] up our
input is not needed here look we all
didn't think that it could get any lower
but hey here we are and you know what
we're the better for it because once you
hit rock bottom then you can climb up as
all of us here who have known the depths
of depravity of Mark Myers mind we know
that there is only up to go there's only
up to go there's only like we can only
go up there's no other way to go plot
off when you're a markiplier fan it's
more than just watching videos it's
about living videos it's about living
the life of the man who inspired all of
us to be worse than we ever thought that
we could be agreed Reginald agreed I
know I should probably throw myself off
a booth but look beyond that we've got
other responsibilities
look I'm gonna level with you guys I
called you here to kill all of you
Reginald look you you you had this
coming for a while you all have done
various things to earn my disdain over
the past few years but chief among them
was you Vaughn yeah you Vaughn I know I
know
you killed my gerbils so how can I be
any kinds of happy about Oh Newberry
look your thing was you subscribe to
PewDiePie and I'm not about that so if
you could just yeah just because I'm
gonna kill you guys doesn't mean that we
can't still be friends
look I poisoned all this food that you
guys are eating oh yeah like you didn't
see it coming okay
oh yeah rabble rabble all you want but
look you can't say that you weren't
deserving y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] you
pagan pieces I felt like I started to go
insane there I really did I was in
another world entirely trying to make
this ruse but was it real could you tell
I know
dare I say I am a master ruse but such a
story to this audience so anyway that
was dinner party hope you enjoyed it
that was a short experience but I had I
went into their way too many times but
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how you thought down the
comments below if you want to try to set
up your own dinner party check out the
link in the description so thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]